his first press conference joe biden
responded to the surge at the southern
border
refusing to accept blame for a crisis on
his watch
people are coming because i'm the nice
guy that's the reason why it's happening
that i'm a decent man or whoever's
phrased that you know that's why they're
coming because no biden's a good guy
truth of the matter is nothing has
changed
as many people came 28 increase in
children to the border in my
administration
well our next guests say they witnessed
a humanitarian crisis
after touring two different migrant teen
facilities in
the state of texas this week here to
share what they saw texas congressman
van taylor who was at the site
in there he is right there in dallas and
august fluger
who was in midland guys good morning to
both of you good morning
okay uh congressman fluger let's start
with you you know joe biden says
i'm open for transparency just not yet
how bad is it that he doesn't want us to
see it
steve the only thing that's open is the
border which we've asked him
repeatedly to close and in the cover of
darkness he established
a facility in midland texas where they
won't answer any questions there's a
lack of transparency somebody a director
inside the facility told me
this is the highest level of trafficking
in her career that she's ever seen
oh my goodness and congressman taylor
you know
joe biden was just talking about why
they're coming they are coming
and you've heard stories from from some
of these migrant children
that down in the cartel country or down
in the uh
triangle countries the cartels are
advertising on the radio
hey now's the time to go let's go hop on
the bus
yeah the the cartels are are making
money off of this humanitarian crisis
uh that was created by reckless rhetoric
out of the white house
um the the the the level of crisis that
we're seeing
uh this is the you know i met with the
commander of the emergency intake
uh center in dallas texas uh
that was established and went from zero
to
over 2 200 children in seven days i mean
so just a dramatic
uh problem that we have a crisis on the
southern border
and they said this is the worst they've
ever seen you know in 30 years
of working for the department of health
and human services uh handling all
different
surges on the border this is beyond
anything they've ever seen
and and the and the the announcement
yesterday of fort bliss
uh being used is just a sign of how bad
it really is
it's so bad you're having to pull in the
military well uh congressman flu
taylor rather you've looked at the
facility
in dallas so you know we've we heard
from the cdc regarding school
kids can be now three feet apart rather
than six feet apart
how close are the kids the sleeping
situation describe that
yeah i mean these are uh they they had
to pull fema cots
and their uh hhs is doing the best they
can i mean they have 500 personnel
working full-time at this facility uh in
dallas
uh and they're sleeping literally uh of
uh head to feet uh the cots are just a
few feet from each other
uh they're they're going around in pods
of 50
uh to go get lunch to do their their
five-minute supervised shower
uh you know and how how these facilities
uh don't become uh coveted hotbeds i
don't know i mean
but they're not designed to do that
they're just designed to help these poor
children to survive
uh and and the humanitarian crisis again
on
the the this administration created is
absolutely heartbreaking
and congressman fluger i understand and
congressman taylor
said this as well that when these kids
come here they've got a phone number in
their pocket or something like that
they have been told that the united
states government will pretty much
fly you anywhere you want to go in the
united states just tell us where you
want to go
and we will make sure you get there well
that's right the
they're being communicated to all
throughout those northern triangle
countries and the people that benefit
from this are the traffickers the
cartels the coyotes the people that are
making money
and the criminal activities is
heartbreaking for the children
um you know and for our communities that
are not safe the children can go
wherever they want
because they know that the border is
open we have repeatedly asked president
biden to visit
and yet his own vice president o'hara
mocking the situation at the border and
it's the kids that are losing and his
policies have incentivized
this criminal behavior and we heard this
week that at least one facility
is at 1556 percent
above capacity and that would make that
a super spreader event during a pandemic
it's just
nuts uh congressman van taylor and
august fluger guys thank you very much
for joining us live